tous les médias toutes les émissions
toutes les chroniques à la fin novembre
ou décembre vont parler du réchauffement
climatique
c'est un enjeu politique un enjeu
mondial est majeur et moi je me suis dit
bon je suis pas scientifique
je pas politique quoique un peu quand
même quand on fait de l'art on est
parfois un peu engagés mais je me suis
dit moi je voudrais plutôt rendre un
hommage à ce qui est beau et faire
comprendre que ce qui est beau et
éphémère et fragile est en danger donc
le film fait le choix grâce à plein de
créateurs qui imaginent des choses
d'ailleurs pour le film fait le choix de
montrer de la nature dont joue avec la
nature et de dire voilà vous aimez vous
protégez vous jouissez des choses ça
peut ne pas durer
vous aimez un arbre faut pas l'abattre
vous aimez les singes vous n'êtes pas
obligé de les tuer vous aimez manger
vous pouvez manger bien et puis on
raconte aussi dans le film l'histoire de
l'art la nature et l'art il ya
trente-huit mille ans les premiers
hommes de néandertal dans leurs cavernes
on fait de l'art sans savoir mais il
avait le talent du geste donc le film
moi je trouve que c'est intéressant
aussi de faire un film qui montre
comment la nature est rentré dans
l'histoire de l'humanité dollar voilà
depuis 38 ans à aujourd'hui